coach first of all congratulations on
the win thank you so much dan thanks for
the opportunity to come on and talk
about our team uh and how did the snow
affect the outcome in your opinion oh I
don't know if it's like the outcome both
teams had to play in it I'm certain that
that each team probably changed their
game plan a little bit I know we did
just more straight ahead running and and
really had to take some precautions in
the kicking game but it was uh it was a
battle as I just heard you saying what a
great game and a great rivalry what is
West Point like today after that win
back to normal all the American people
would be happy to know we we got
everybody's going to class and get
prepared for final exams and and back to
the routine of what's expected of a
cadet the great celebration last night
on the steps of the mess hall in
Washington Hall just incredible all
4,400 cadets out there our
superintendent general Caslon our team
captains raising the trophy it was
really a great celebration can you get
too caught up in trying to beat Navy
every year I know that it's it's it's
everything you know feels like it the
swimming pool I think has beat Navy on
the bottom of it so can you get too
caught up in it coach and not remember
that you have a full football schedule
there it's not just beating Navy I think
our players do a really good job of
handling something that we try to do as
a programs we can talk about it all year
long
up until the really the preparation for
our first game begins
throughout preseason camp we we talk
about every opponent we really kind of
design a plan for the entire season
but once we we really dive into the
preparation for Game one we turn it off
completely until those weeks bubble back
up that we have a chance to get ready
for the for the big army-navy game so
our kids have handled it well and
I think it's allowed us to just really
concentrate and focus on on the other
opponents that we have those those are
those are tough enough as it is not to
mention the the army-navy game if you
want every game except for the Navy game
can you have a successful season not not
completely no and it's one of the great
things about the game and also once it
tough things about the game this there
there is such an emphasis and such a
sense of pride in winning that game that
it really is a season within itself the
Armed Forces Bowl against San Diego
State will be the next game that'll be a
couple of days before Christmas
Continental Tire coaches corner Jeff
Monken the army head coach we did have a
bet attached to this game of course this
was entertainment purposes only coach
but we have a shower of shame where we
pour a mysterious a mystery liquid on
the loser and one of my doughnuts Seaton
O'Connor took they had the audacity to
take Navy and he lost the bet don't know
if you have a suggestion I'd like to
know on behalf of West Point and the
army what would you suggest for shower
Shane I think if we put some squid and
the blender and made it night you know
it's got to be liquid
I think whole raw squid would be great
but if you can't do that blend it up and
just let him have it
Wow squid is there any to split the Navy
squids right oh the squids
you're an army fan I heard you say yeah
and you're at least your chance for the
right thing oh yeah oh yeah I always
root for the right team I just wasn't
aware of us the squids there now we did
have somebody suggest now how's this
coach I'm thinking navy bean soup and
squid absolutely there you go
even better coach I hope to see you next
season Congrats good luck in the bowl
game and we appreciate you joining us I
hope we'll see you next year - thank you
so much we're looking forward to the
opportunity play in the postseason and
thanks again for the opportunity be on
with you and talk about our great team
so have a great day and
and maybe there you go that's coach
Monken the army head coach cotton entire
Coaches Corner
you got to get that in Continental Tire
Coach's Corner proud supporter the Dan
Patrick show Continental Tire dot-com
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show ass
[Music]